and thank you for inviting me over here
to the game today oh and i probably
appreciate it i mean
you're my best friend wow thanks man hey
you know what you're my best friend too
cool yeah yeah wrote a song about it
you're my best friend together we can
change the world
[Music]
i've been trying to reach out to you all
day
are we on for tonight
jeez what you can't catch me you can't
catch me
i'm lance moore touchdown [ __ ] what
pause
oh shoot keegan's been texting me
sorry dude missed your texts i
assumed we'd meet at the bar whatever
i don't care
sorry dude missed your texts i assumed
we'd meet at the bar
whatever i don't care whatever
i don't care what the [ __ ]
is his problem do you even
want to hang out do you even want to
hang out
oh that's considerate
like i said whatever like i said
whatever
this guy jesus you are
priceless ah
you're the one who's priceless
this this [ __ ] right here
oh he wants to okay okay
you want to go right now huh
guess i could do that um okay
okay let's go he said okay okay let's go
all right you know what you know what
you want to really do this now
keegan you nut you're not putting me out
yeah let's do it oh yeah [ __ ]
first round's mine oh no oh no there
gonna be no rounds [ __ ]
it's gonna be a street fight this is not
about because tonight we got a party
no buddy like i said
first round's mine a beer and a gimlet
for my partner right
what's that uh i i got you a baseball
bat with
nails in it
for my post-apocalyptic jackie robinson
costume how did you know
all right so we have to remember h5 okay
um oh i got it high five oh i see oh
that's good i see what you're trying to
do they're trying to figure out a
mnemonic device
uh high fives came out in the 70s that's
when they were invented that's a seven
yeah there's two of us
so so if you subtract two from seven
that's five okay
great so you got it so yeah and then um
there's five major
groups why are you going on oh no you're
going to love this it's just this is fun
for me because it's a puzzle no no
puzzle okay
five five major food groups there's meat
vegetables
grain dairy and fruit okay my favorite
fruit is pineapple
but you know that we got it already
pineapple comes from hawaii
okay and my favorite current show
is hawaii five-o y-five-o okay so that's
it we're done
we're done and scott scott khan
is the star wars 5-0 we're really
talking about scott his father is james
khan who's one of the
five major stars what's wrong with the
one of the five major huge stars yeah
each right of the godfather movies so
it's kong
pacino brandon and um
diane keaton yes dan keaton and it's
easy to remember her name because her
name
is the same last name as buster keaton
and michael we're just going
through comedians and when you laugh you
say ha
stop stop stop stop stop stop
you see what you're doing you're over
complicating the whole thing we already
had it
you just you just you're just making it
more difficult just like you do
everything
i left my phone in the car
which is wait hold up uh dap
nope no it was it was handshake no i got
it i got it i got it
buster keaton and michael keaton same
last name is diane keaton is one of the
five
huge stars on the godfather movies
keaton brando
duvall pacino and james khan oh who is
the father of scott
who's
damn what up vegan
what's up three days me and you free
drinks they can be a chill this is gonna
be our [ __ ] right here dog
is gonna be my let's get some jams going
up in this [ __ ] right now you got the
number one track in the country right
now
roll with me oh
[ __ ] that's my jam right there i love
this song
i love this song too man everybody loves
this song what
here we go
[Music]
girl you know that i got what you need
see don't get greedy
give it up sweetly let me set that body
free cause what you got
you got to give it to me what what
[Music]
ever since i was rocking a onesie i know
that you was second
to none growing up and learning abcs and
one two threes hoping you'd learn we
were meant to be
even way back then every little [ __ ]
knows a perfect tense
but then you know i grow up and got a
little bit
older a little bit bolder busting off my
shoulders almost a man those playground
feelings grew stronger
when you wait much longer now with me
bro you've been longer
[Music]
take it right now
[Music]
what the hell don't turn it off just
because you don't know it what are we
gonna do when we get to vegas no no
no no no no no don't change the subject
about what we're gonna do in vegas
if you don't know the words just admit
you don't know the the words i told you
why would i make up that i know don't
know
that's ridiculous man no i know the word
it seems like you didn't know the word i
know the word hey listen hey listen to
me man what what
i know the words that's right everybody
knows okay no no it's not okay because
you obviously don't believe me
hey dude on our friendship
i know the words to roll with me
okay i'm sorry
it's all right just let it go i'm sorry
that was stupid stupid
turn it back up yo i love that track so
much i'm sorry i gotta play it again
this is wrong with me 1.3 kb
with me
yeah that really hurt
[Applause]
all right oh my gosh that is crazy
oh my god oh my gosh hey uh i forgot to
tell you congratulations
on getting the new job oh thanks man
appreciate it awesome yeah and thank you
for
inviting me over here to the game today
oh no probably appreciate it you're my
best friend
wow thanks man hey you know what you're
my best friend too cool yeah
yeah wrote a song about it
not gonna sing it or anything because
that would be gay that's pretty gay
all right i'll give it a shot
wally you're my best friend
together we can change the world
we've been together through thick and
thin playing ball and
talking to girls wally i'm so proud of
you
you know you're taking all of my advice
wait stop stop stop stop
what advice oh um
it's just a song dude i mean like can i
finish
and then we can oh okay
you've done everything i've asked of you
and you never ever questioned twice
you're talking about thank you for doing
what i
told you to
your achievements are all so mine
my padawan you make your sensei
proud living your life living your life
living your life to my design
that was the weirdest song i've ever
heard in my life you have listened to
your elders i'm older than you never
forget the words i
say um don't like your songs
to my creation no i'm not i have shown
you the way except for that you haven't
you haven't
modulated just say what you like the
white wolf guys just cubs through the
planes of the caribou
shut up
i have done all i can
the rest is up to
you
my wolf cup is all grown up
know